not just myself you grew up in the deep
south I grew up in the dirty dirty and
there's the dirty dirty where I'm from
in Mississippi yes I love it so I grew
up in the south this weather how hard
was that growing up in that kind of
environment being gay like really hard I
had to wait honestly I grew up in a
conservative Christian just like ultra
ultra red part of the state and it was
really hard for me to kind of like come
to grips with that but I was blessed
with a really loving family and it
wasn't easy for them at first but we all
navigated it together and came out a
stronger family on the other side of it
[Applause]
friends I always like asking people in
the limelight about that because a lot
of people don't have the confidence to
do that and so that's why I always ask
people I like how did you do it or when
did you do what we're seeing like a new
South emerge and I think I credit people
like you honestly I've always
appreciated your support of the LGBTQ
community
I loved your tie it up music video or
you have gay couples getting married
alongside straight couples in this video
I just find that love is love is love
right love is hard enough like to find
so when you find it who the hell cares
what it looks like like if you're the
same or different I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this